bonjour anastasia sa poche qui n'a merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes maître de conférences en
géopolitique à sciences po je le disais
spécialiste des relations entre l'europe
et la russie c'est cet après midi donc
cette réunion tripartite erdo anne gut
hérésie lenski c'est d'ailleurs la
première fois que les présidents turc et
ukrainien vont se rencontrer depuis le
début de la guerre le principal sujet on
l'a dit c'est l'exportation des céréales
quelle île constat aujourd'hui selon
vous elle a repris ses exportations de
céréales mais pas au rythme escompté il
faut en faire plus bien sûr ce sont des
dizaines de millions de tonnes de
céréales que le cren export tous les ans
elle est responsable am sol pour 12% de
l'export des céréales mondiale mais à
la reprise elle est très modeste qu'on a
entendu cession des parcs de milliers de
tonnes pas 2 millions de tonnes et un
des points importants pour l'ukraine
dans ces négociations
c'est élargir
arriver à trouver des moyens d'élargir
le corridor des exportations de céréales
jusqu'à vendre millions de tonnes ce qui
permettrait bien sûr à l'ukraine à
remplir son budget aussi et inclura
d'autres d'autres
matériaux d'exportation tels que les
métaux par exemple un autre point très
important pour tous les trois partis
c'est bien sûr ceux qui étaient
invoquées de là plusieurs via c'est la
tentative donné que si ea
de fer d'organiser en compte entre
présidence qui préside un petit ce qui
en soit on peut s'en douter parce que la
russie à ce stade même si les combats
sont arrivés en
amour rien ne bouge beaucoup à ce stade
la russie n'est pas encore me semble pas
être prête à négocier et poutine a
réfusé à négocier directement avec
céline ce qui peut-être jusqu'à à des
conditions deviennent plus favorables à
la russie ou se voir jamais ensuite
d'autres points par contre très
importante pour le new c'est bien sûr le
pont sur les visites potentiel de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique a sur le site de zappos rivière
pour voir la situation sur place
aqua l'ukraine
n'était pas très supportable parce que
il ne supportait pas beaucoup c'est à
cette proposition telle quelle avant que
ça ne soit pas vu en tant que
reconnaissance de la contrôle du
contrôle russe de sept territoires et de
la centrale en soi et la fin pour
l'ukraine bien sûr le point très
important de négociation avec la turquie
seront à l'aide financière et militaire
ainsi que pour la turquie la
participation des entreprises turques
dans un des projets de reconstruction de
l'ukraine et cela n'a échappé à personne
le grand absent de cette réunion
tripartite c'est bien sûr la russie vous
parlez de l'élargissement des corridors
également de la sécurité autour de la
centrale de zaporizhya peut-on obtenir
quelque chose sont les russes autour de
la table
effectivement l'absence de la russie
c'est la volonté de la russie même
comme comme je viens d'évoquer donc
président poutine refuse à être autour
de la même table avec président zine ce
qui est son niveau le plus haut
dirigeant c'est pas possible sans le
président de la russie donc c'est c'est
le choix de la russie et c'est aussi le
rôle de la turquie qu'elle exploite
beaucoup en accroissant pendant ce
moment à son rôle en tant que le
puissance diplomatique régionale
puissance militaire etc sera le rôle de
la russie ensuite d'aller négocier avec
de la turquie par vont ensuite aller à
négocier avec la russie la suite de tout
ce qui est leur gisement du corridor et
les garanties de sécurité bien sûr c'est
effectivement pourquoi c'est la turquie
a pas un important gain autres états
parce que à ce stade c'est seulement la
turquie qui a réussi à s'établir en tant
que pouvoir des pneumatiques dans le
sens que quand elle gagne aussi il ya
des résultats tous les autres
négociations ou à peine ou échange avec
le présent us par d'autres leaders
d'état n'ont pas encore à donner des
résultats tangibles alors justement
c'était ma prochaine question que gagne
pour l'instant le médiateur de ce
dossier rejeb tayyip erdogan le
président turc against il
il gagne déjà 1 de
croissance de son influence régionale la
reconnaissance et de
depuis aide son état en tant que
partenaire incontournable déjà par
l'otan dans le centre de quelle nature
qui se permettaient beaucoup de choses
qui ne sont pas des cibles pour d'autres
membres de l'otan sont permis cible pour
la turquie a à cause de son situation à
géographique et à son position
diplomatique donc cette position va être
encore plus renforcée ensuite la turquie
si ce rôle de l'équilibriste entre eux
et le seul médiateur crédible entre
l'ukraine et la russie avec chacun des
deux n et s'établit en tant que
partenaire fiable et important sur le
plan militaire financière et politique
et ça ça permet à turquie à la fois
d'assurer ses propres aux musulmans de
l'énergie russe malgré les sanctions
c'est le permet grâce à ce renforcement
de son standing au sein de l'otan de
ignorer les sanctions contre la russie
et faire ce qu'il veut dans ses propres
relations avec la russie dans ses
intérêts stratégiques
continuer de construction à des quatre
réacteurs nucléaires russes sur son
territoire dans le cadre du projet
akkuyu et aussi de devenir en
négociateur clé dont beaucoup dépend
pour l'approvisionnement mondial des
céréales a envie de la situation de
crise de régime merci anastasia sa poche
qui n'a d'avoir ce midi accepté
l'invitation de france24 merci beaucoup
à vous et belle journée le combattent
dans le donbass depuis